[Music]
is this clark this
uh interstellar comic right big news
i don't see clark oh maybe he's still
sleeping
dad some of clark's larger fragments are
now expected to enter our atmosphere
that's right and now these are just what
are they saying
it's more of the same
[Music]
where are they going
i don't know one of the first chunks is
about to hit
only part of it let's go in the ocean
hey where's the explosion
we now are getting word that the
fragment has hit
central florida wait are some more
pieces gonna hit
come on let's go put the sky's on fire
two days they got it all wrong there's a
ton of fragments planet killers
space agencies are predicting an
extinction-level event
we're going to be together all right get
them we're just trying to get to safety
they've been tracking the military
flights to bunkers and greenland
it's their only chance
[Music]
largest fragment will hit in less than
24 hours
i swear i'm gonna get my family
in a bunker i know you will also
[Music]
if you are carrying this broadcast seek
shelter immediately
listen what's going on
immediately seek shelter immediately
you